hey it's adam for wired i am super
excited because i've figured out a way
to make sure that san diego comic con is
no longer too crowded and it will never
have to leave san diego and you can have
as much of it as you want here's the
trick
band letting people take pictures of
other people in costume now i know we
like to take pictures of the cosplayers
but i did a little bit of math figuring
that it takes about two seconds to take
a picture with your phone or with an
older camera
counting you know shutter lag and the
time it takes to let things spin up
again and to spin up your photo app
right
figure it's about 260 000 pictures at
the con roughly if half the 130 000
attendees take pictures and they take
like 40 pictures over the course of four
days that ends up being uh you know 260
000 pictures times two seconds
144 hours you could have five more days
of convention
and when you take those pictures what do
you do you stand in the middle where
people are walking and you get like a
five foot distance between subject and
photographer that ends up being 60
square feet of bubble
multiply that times 130 000 pictures you
end up with 7.8 million square feet of
space the whole exhibition space the
convention center is only i looked this
up 615 000 square feet i've just given
you like three more convention centers
you can thank me later nerds
for more coverage of the con wired.com
you